Madonna was at the DC Women's march on
Saturday she lets slip that she has
thought a lot about blowing up the White
House in reaction to Donald Trump's
election as president he or she is
addressing the crowd of about half a
million people more than the number that
attended Donald Trump's inauguration by
the way take a look I'm angry yes I am
outraged yes I have thought an awful lot
about blowing up the White House but I
know that this won't change anything we
cannot fall into despair she also used
the f-word three times CNN and MSNBC cut
away after the third time I assume Fox
News wasn't airing this to begin with so
they had nothing to cut away from a bad
idea to joke about this obviously
Madonna has no actual intent nor plan to
blow up the White House reportedly this
did trigger awareness from Secret
Service I think the funniest part about
all this is that right-wingers on
Twitter and online they're saying we
were offended by Madonna's use of the F
word and saying F Trump if grabbed him
by the [ __ ] wasn't enough for you not
to vote for Trump you don't really get
to complain about Madonna using the F
word on TV it's such blatant fake drama
double standard hypocrisy isn't it yeah
I think they're going to need a safe
space I mean I don't think this was the
right move by Madonna's part I think
there are plenty of ways to get your
effective speech out of course without
making any threats like this this was
too far she did eventually say that she
thought about it but then realized that
it wouldn't actually change anything and
I think that's the key part to take from
what Madonna said here again I'm against
joking about blowing up the White House
in such a public way when you're such a
prominent person but she did make the
right point which is even if we blew up
the White House it wouldn't change
anything to change things you actually
need to organize voting is a key part of
it turnout alone could have blocked
Trump from even winning we wouldn't even
be having this conversation right now
and and the the interesting thought is
that she immediately retracted the
entire blow up the White House saying
saying it was
interpreted I take it back period
Republicans like Trump were threatening
Obama constantly for eight years
including with this whole fake birth
certificate he's not an American thing
they've never apologized or retracted
anything and Madonna
within hours says yeah that idea
shouldn't actually have said that if
you're going to take away anything from
this it's that you can't vote for [ __ ]
grabber and chief and be offended at the
F word and number two you need to
organize and turnout alone could have
blocked any of this nonsense from even
starting